We don't want to negotiate with people
over evaluation and you could talk to
any of the nine companies that got in
and ask them. Yeah. We didn't negotiate
evaluation. We just gave them what they
said on the application.
Nobody ever talks about it. Like
[laughter] it was it was written in the
application. We're like, "Great."
Like there was no discussion. That was
the deal. Isn't that awesome? [laughter]
Cuz dude, I don't want to dude, I don't
I don't know. Negotiate valuation with
founders? That's no fun.
All right, this is Dalton plus Michael
and today we're going to get an update
from Standard Capital. So, you funded a
bunch of companies.
You know stuff now that you didn't know
before.
>> Yeah. Why don't we just start with like
remind people what the process was. Like
what what was the process? What was the
innovation for this thing? Yeah, I mean,
look, the the idea for Standard was to
take what we know worked well from Y
Combinator and apply it to the next
round. And Series A's. Yeah, to Series
A's because look, we
how many companies have you and I funded
at YC? Oh, a lot.
>> Thousands. Uh
>> [laughter]
>> each Yeah.
>> of companies.
>> of companies. Part of the job at YC was
to help founders raise the A and so I
had a pretty good mental model of what
they were experiencing and it was funny
how
>> And we also raised A's ourselves. So,
There was that.
>> Yes. It's funny how little uh overlap
there was on the process to get into YC
with raising the next round. It was an
entirely different skill and the idea
was to make it kind of the same thing.
So, how many companies did y'all end up
funding? So far, we have funded nine
companies and that is not announced
anywhere in fact. Maybe by the time
>> [laughter]
>> Maybe by the time we Uh release this
video. Nice. Breaking news. So far,
two have been announced and are on our
website as of the moment we're recording
this. And then biggest thing you
learned, like biggest kind of
headline takeaway now that you've run
one cycle, either something that's been
reconfirmed or something that's new that
you didn't expect.
>> I think what really surprised uh PB and
Brian and myself is the following. How
many times have we coached founders on
launching? Mhm.
>> What do we say? We say, "Look, founder,
you're going to have to launch and
launch again and launch again and and no
one will have heard of your thing.
>> Yep. So, just like keep launching and
it'll take years and then someday maybe
people will have heard
will know know of the name of your
company.
>> will have heard of it. Right? Like
that's And so, this was kind of like my
internal thing, which is, you know, uh
some folks would know about what we're
doing, but I didn't sober expectations.
>> Yeah. Precisely.
>> Yeah. And the good news is we were
surprised that um it seems like everyone
heard about it and we got way more
applications than we expected and I had
to go read a lot of applications.
>> [laughter]
>> I basically
I scheduled a
small amount of time to read
applications. I needed about three times
as long as I had scheduled.
>> You were [__] by applications again.
>> Oh, I know.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude,
I had to work through
You you have to keep on doing this to
yourself.
>> doing this to myself. I don't know how
I'm doing this.
>> [laughter]
>> Um but again, I was I had a smile on my
face as I as I ruined another family
vacation.
>> [laughter]
>> So, that was great and then we had to
not had to, we were we had the
excitement of interviewing lots of
companies, way more than we expected. So
again, it kind of messed all of our
schedules up in a very high quality way.
>> That's cool. And what was cool is we
were like, "Wow, these are really good
companies."
>> Yes.
>> And what I learned is this had good word
of mouth. Okay. Like founders heard
about this and were pretty excited. You
know, it's funny cuz I remember hearing
the story of Standard Capital and kind
of equating it to all the experiences we
had
and all the conversations we had with
VCs who were like, "No, our process is
great. Founders love our process." and
just being like, "That's not
what I'm hearing on the ground, you
know."
in the trenches.
And um
to your point about kind of the word of
mouth got out there, this was just a
different process, right? So, like give
me a sense from the deadline
>> Yep.
>> of applying, give me a bit of a timeline
here for when I knew I was going to have
a Series A. Like walk me through that
timeline. Sure thing. So, within um
let's call it five days, seven days of
the application deadline,
>> Yeah. everyone that we uh did a
first round of interviews with,
>> Yeah. we did the first round of
interviews. So, we're talking about a
about a week after the application
deadline. So, you read the applications
and did first interviews within a week.
>> Yeah, or we got the invites out by then.
>> Oh, invites. Invites. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Yes. No, but we did them all
immediately.
>> Great, great, great, great. And then the
way the Standard process works is
there's two meetings. So, then we had a
second meeting for the folks that were
most promising from the first round.
>> Okay. And that was in person. Okay. And
so, we met with everyone in person.
>> Great. And then we made the final
decision two days after that.
Okay.
>> So, the whole shebang was two weeks. The
total amount of time that the founders
spent was the amount of time they spent
on the application,
>> Yeah. the first interview, which is
longer than a YC interview. Um it's 20
minutes. Oh.
Danger.
I clear my calendar. And then a second
meeting, which was in person
>> Okay. and was 30 minutes.
>> Okay. And so, if you just think about
how much time did the did the founders
spend? Well, they had to spend a lot of
time backchanneling, right?
>> [laughter]
>> Um
it was time efficient and we got back to
folks fast and again, it's not everyone,
you know, the vast majority of people
did not get a yes.
>> But in terms of how much time they
spent,
>> Yeah. What is a good applica- after
reading the applications, give me a
sense of what you felt like a good
application time wise would have taken
to to write? A couple hours. I actually
asked a couple of founders. There's one
where it took a little bit more for her
when I talked to her about it. She I
think she said three. But I think
similar to the YC application, it's kind
of smart to fill it out and answer the
questions for yourself. There's a lot of
questions about how this gets really big
and I think every founder
>> Yeah. should go fill it out. And so,
it's actually a little different than a
YC application in that sense cuz we're
asking more product market fit type
questions. I would recommend going
through the exercise.
>> basically telling me
in let's call it a four hours of active
time investment in a founder,
I get a yes no on a Series A. Yep. I'm
just thinking about the number of times
where you and I spent four hours talking
to a founder. Just our time talking with
the founder. Let alone Series A about
the Series A.
>> [laughter]
>> Not deck editing, not pitching, not back
and forths. That's different.
>> Yeah. And again, a lot of these cases,
like we really we did due diligence.
>> Yeah. And so, that meant
send us
>> Well, we were like, "Send us a bunch of
stuff." Oh, yeah. And if you
are properly run, it should not be hard
to send us some stuff.
>> Yes.
>> Does that make sense? And so, it's our
job to like dig through it to do all the
diligence, but from the founder's
perspective, it was like, "Okay, cool.
Here are the docs." Yeah. You're going
to have a new application cycle.
What is an interesting piece of advice
you would give future applicants? We are
setting this up
to really reward multiple time
applicants.
>> Okay.
Where once you apply once, if you want
to apply again, just use mostly the same
application.
>> Yep. Yep. And then just change the
things that are different.
>> That's very YC similar. Right.
Right? And we would actually encourage
folks to apply earlier if they're not
even sure.
>> Sure. Um
>> No penalty for that. No penalty for it.
In fact, it's good.
>> That was a big YC one, too, right? Two
data points is so easy. Like, "Oh, what
what what's changed in the last three
months?" That was just so much easier to
get excited.
>> Exactly. Yeah. So, that's that's one and
then I think number two, we're doing
something no one has ever done before,
which is have founders name their own
price and state their valuation.
>> Yes.
>> And some folks
had a really easy time with that and
picked really good valuations um
relative to their traction.
>> Mhm. Does that make sense? Like some
folks had tons of traction, picked
higher valuations. Some folks with less
traction, picked lower. And so, that's
good and those were the people that got
in.
>> Yeah. There were some folks that I think
did not do themselves any favors around
valuation and I don't know, maybe they
didn't get advice from people or and
again, just to be super clear for the
record here, we don't want to negotiate
with people over valuation and you could
talk to any of the nine companies that
got in and ask them.
>> Yeah. We didn't negotiate valuation. We
just gave them what they said on the
application.
Nobody ever talks about it. Like it was
>> [laughter]
>> it was written in the application. We're
like, "Great."
Like there was no discussion.
>> That was the deal. Isn't that awesome?
Cuz dude, I don't want to dude, I don't
I don't know. Negotiate valuation with
founders? That's no fun. And so, I do
think there are some folks made some
feedback to have other folks that
>> Mhm.
might want to think about that a little
bit and I tried to dig into it when I
spoke with them Yeah. and I think they
would often admit they hadn't thought
about it much and they were just kind of
basing it on other rounds that they had
heard about.
>> It's a cool and different model to kind
of ask the founder to make this question
versus like theoretically the market in
Series A land will make this
determination. On the other hand, it's
kind of like refreshing to be, "How much
money do you want to accomplish what
goal you want to accomplish and how much
of your company do you want to sell to
do that?" Yep.
In some ways it's kind of good, right?
>> [laughter]
>> Some ways it's pretty straightforward.
But I could see, you know, and we love
the mid with mean, right? Like I could
see
Well, Dalton, right? Like, "Okay, I
haven't pitched VCs yet and I know that
if I had a competitive round,
that like I could raise at this crazy
price and like my competitor, this other
company, raised at this crazy price. So,
like
shouldn't I be pricing this like the the
the valuation I would need to not
consider pitching other investors?
Do you have an Excel spreadsheet I can
use to fill this out?
You know, I could see kind of a a mid
with way of thinking about that and like
hey, it's my job as CEO to get the right
price for my company, right? So, like
where am I where am I overthinking this?
I think it's
folks were shocked that we just reject
them instead of negotiate over price.
So, it was just like a misunderstanding
of like
>> they
No.
>> [laughter]
>> Because again, we have so many
applicants. We're going to spend our
time Yeah. with folks where again, some
folks had higher prices, but they had
crazy traction. So, we'd rather spend
the time with the fastest growing
startups that are growing, you know,
Yeah. 10x year over year on the higher
prices.
>> Yeah. I think the missing information
was like, yeah, we're not we're not
going to counter. We'll just not. It's
almost funny cuz from that perspective,
it's kind of like read the manual. Like
we were serious.
A little bit.
>> Like like this is
we don't negotiate these deals. Yeah, I
mean and you should think about it
linearly, which is if someone was to
choose a
120 post, yeah, their odds of acceptance
the bar is twice as high as 60 post.
>> Yeah. It's not like equally likely to
get in with the same company.
>> So if you're going twice as fast, you're
twice as good of a market, blah blah
blah blah sure. Totally. And there's 120
post companies that are great companies.
We want to fund them, but man, it's got
to look Yeah. very exciting. Yeah.
That's tricky. It's funny cuz I think
that I remember in YC days
some group of people, you know, being
like, oh, you now that we're in, it's
time for you to pitch us. Why should do
YC? And I was kind of like, no, no, no,
like
it's completely up to you. If you don't
want to do it, don't like don't do it.
>> [laughter]
>> And it was just
oh, this isn't like normal.
Like we purposely built this to not like
normal fundraising.
Yes. Like that was the
>> This is a way to opt out. It's
[laughter] This is like an opt out move,
which is you could do this or you could
do that. It's not like a mush. It's like
it's a different thing. It's a different
thing.
And those are the folks that did the got
in. Again, like the the folks that were
really successful with our process.
>> Yeah.
They wanted that.
>> They were like, we haven't talked any
investors, we haven't built a deck. We
just applied and if we get in, we're
going to do it.
>> Yeah.
And that's exactly what happened. I did
talk to a number of VCs who were like,
no, but people, you know, one, this is
an important skill, pitching a company
with a slide deck. And I'm like,
interesting. Okay. Sure.
Um I don't know that I'd put that on the
top five most important skills for
building a great company, but fair,
great, sure.
Or two,
this was a really common one. It's like,
we have complete knowledge of the good
companies and we are already actively
scouting,
communicating, and like we know everyone
who's good.
Which I just remember that was how
people felt at YC. It's like, well,
obviously it's going to be full of [__]
companies cuz we know all the good
founders. And again, think about the the
ramifications of that. Do you actually
think you know all the good companies?
Shut down.
>> [laughter]
>> Like
shut down your fund. Please.
Cuz you're admitting it's a zero-sum
game with no margin.
>> Yes. Yes.
Like if that's your mentality, leave the
industry.
>> Yeah, yeah, yeah. Because it means
you're so like disillusioned with the
work.
>> Yes. You're investing commodity dollars.
>> love the work.
>> Yes. That's a sign
you shouldn't do this anymore.
>> That's fair. So, uh last but not least,
when is the next time people can apply?
And the question I always got,
can I apply late? Yep. The next deadline
is going to be in early January. And so
we're going to open up applications in
sort of like late December. So lots of
time. It'll be kind of quiet, I presume,
for a lot of folks in that time of the
year. So good time to to work on your
application there. Yeah. And then yes,
you can totally apply late. We are I
read all the applications that come in.
Definitely looking at the late ones.
Yeah. The advantage for us of folks all
applying around the deadline is we can
just like crank through these things
super fast and do a ton of interviews in
one day.
>> Yeah. It's it's super efficient.
>> Yeah. And so that is the the benefit,
but yeah, I've been reading every
application as they come in. I always
love when we got that question at YC.
It's like, sure. Like just like, you
know, like let's not make this
number of times we got like got the
question,
can I apply late? And I'm like, there's
a thing on there. Just do it. Just do
it. Or don't do it. Anyways, this sounds
like a great update. I look forward to
learning what you guys learn after cycle
two.
Sounds good.
>> Thanks, Michael. Cheers.